- [Instructor] When Christopher Columbus
first arrived in the Americas,
he had no way of knowing that he had
set off a complex chain of events
that would lead to everything
from humanity's largest
demographic disaster,
to the founding of a new
nation nearly 300 years later,
to you watching a video about the history
of that nation right at this very moment.
It's strange, right?
Columbus's voyages to the New World
and those of the navigators and
settlers who came after him,
changed the worlds to an extent
rarely seen in human history.
Let's briefly review the effects
of these transatlantic voyages on Europe,
Africa, and the Americas
between 1492 and 1607,
the period between first contact
and the establishment
of the first permanent
English settlement in the
Americas at Jamestown.
So you might call this the pre-British era
of colonization in the Americas.
So what changes did these voyages cause?
Well, there were demographic changes,
and by demographic I mean shifts
in the structure of populations.
The indigenous populations of the Americas
faced a catastrophic decline in numbers
as a result of diseases
carried by Europeans.
On the flip side, the
populations of Africa and Europe
grew with the introduction
of nutritious foods
found in the Americas
like potatoes and corn.
Contact also led to the
creation of new cultural groups,
as indigenous people,
Europeans, and Africans
mixed in the New World
and had children together.
The transatlantic voyages
also led to economic changes,
including shifts in the
systems of money and labor.
Spain extracted gold and silver
from the New World by force,
compelling indigenous
people and then later
enslaved Africans to labor in mines.
These riches flooded into Europe
and caused a huge increase in prices,
which may have led to the development
of banking and capitalism there.
And European demand for
laborers in New World mines
and plantations led to the
expansion of the slave trade,
resulting in the forced migration
of millions of African
people to the Americas.
Columbus's discovery also fostered
political changes in
Europe and the New World,
as other European countries wanted
to claim colonies of their own.
And the power structure
among indigenous nations
changed, too, with the
addition of European allies
and the destruction of large
portions of the population,
leading to the downfall of
powerful empires like the Aztecs.
The cultures of indigenous people changed,
as Europeans introduced new material goods
and animals into their environment.
For example, the Spanish
brought horses to North America,
changing the society of plains people,
who could now hunt and follow
herds of bison on horseback.
And new religious practices
also emerged in the Americas,
as indigenous peoples
combined their own beliefs
with those of Catholicism.
By examining the effects
of transatlantic voyages,
what we're really doing is practicing
the skill of causation.
This is probably the most important
skill in the historian's toolbox.
Understanding and arguing about
what caused an event to happen,
or what consequences an event
had on society later on.
Now this seems pretty straightforward.
For example, a cause and
effect statement might be,
I slept through my alarm this
morning, so I missed the bus.
Cause: oversleeping.
Effect: missed bus.
Notice that the effect has
to happen after the cause.
Missing the bus didn't
cause me to oversleep.
So until we invent the time machine,
effects must happen later than causes.
But there can be a few
pitfalls to watch out for
when we try to determine
causes and effects.
First, not everything has
just one cause and one effect.
For example, maybe I
slept through my alarm
because I stayed up too
late last night watching TV.
That's another cause for missing the bus.
And there could be more than one effect
of sleeping through the alarm,
not just missing the bus,
but also missing my test in first period.
Which was the most important
cause of missing the bus,
oversleeping or watching too much TV?
And which was the more important effect
of sleeping through my alarm,
missing the bus or missing the test?
These kinds of questions are
what historians argue about.
Which was the most important
cause of Atlantic exploration,
competition between European countries,
or the desire to convert
new people to Catholicism?
Another potential pitfall
is one you might have seen
in a science class or in statistics,
which is correlation
does not imply causation.
In other words, two events
aren't necessarily related
just because they happened
close together in time or space.
For example, although epidemic
diseases led to the deaths
of indigenous people in the New World
at the same time that the
discovery of new foodstuffs
increased the population
of Europe and Africa,
the introduction of diseases didn't cause
those populations to increase.
Those were just two things
that happened simultaneously.
One way you can check whether one event
was caused by an earlier one,
is to ask whether event
B would have happened
whether or not event A happened.
The populations of Europe and Africa
would likely have
increased with the addition
of those new foods even if there
hadn't been any epidemic diseases at all.
The last thing that we
wanna take into account
while we're thinking about causation,
is the difference between short
and long-term effects of an event.
Missing my first period test might
be a short-term effect of oversleeping,
but failing the class
because I missed tests
would be a long-term effect.
And maybe because I failed that test
I ended up focusing on a
different subject in school,
and heading into a different career.
That would be a really long-term effect.
Think about the effects
of transatlantic voyages
that we've discussed,
and see if you can categorize them
into short-term effects
and long-term effects.
You might find that some
things fit into both categories
as processes that started immediately
but then went on for a long time,
like the epidemic
diseases that immediately
affected indigenous people,
but then continued to reshape
the demographic composition
of the Americas for hundreds of years.
So let's recap what we've
learned about causation.
First, historians argue about causation
as they try to pin down the
reason an event happened.
Second, causes must happen before effects.
Third, a single event might
have more than one cause
or more than one effect,
and some causes and effects may be
more important than others.
Fourth, events that
happened near to each other
in time or space, aren't
necessarily related
by a cause and effect relationship.
Coincidences happen.
And lastly, causes may have both short
and long-term effects, immediate results,
and downstream impacts that go
far beyond the time in question.